MAJD BAKAR: Hi, everyone.
My name is Majd Bakar, and
I run the engineering team
that's possible for
Chrome Casson Cars.
And this is John Affaki, who is
Engineering Manager for Google
Cast SDK.
Today we're going to talk to you
a little bit about Google Cast
Evolution, and
some of the things
you should expect from
us in the coming years.
Nearly a year ago last July,
we announced Chromecast,
the small little
evolutionary device
that allows you to extend
your favorite content
from your mobile device
to the big screen.
Be it from a phone, tablet,
or laptop to any HDTV, all
for a mere $35.
Google Cast is the
technology behind Chromecast.
It allows developers to enable
multi-screen experiences
straddling mobile devices
and large screen displays.
And earlier this
year we also released
the Google Cast SDK and
the Cast Developer Program,
which now has over 6,000
developers building application
forecast around the world.
Let's talk a little bit
about our vision and goals
for Google Cast.
[INAUDIBLE] the
goals we're going
to see in the game
in a few minutes.
First off, our goal is to
redefine how people interact
with their TVs in
the living room,
and offer them the most
compelling experience
to bring their favorite
content and application
to the large screen.
Second, we wanted to
build an ecosystem
to proliferate these
experiences-- an ecosystem that
brings more Cast-ready
devices and more
Cast-enabled applications
and services to all users.
And we want that ecosystem
to be open to anyone
to participate in
and be part of.
Finally, we wanted to make sure
that wherever Cast is used,
it's consistent to the user and
consistent for you to develop.
Users do not need to learn a new
way to use their favorite app.
And you, the
developer, do not need
to learn a new
development for that.
Let's first dive into
the interaction model.
One of the things
that was obvious to us
was how hard it is to
interact with the 10 foot UI.
Whether you're browsing
a large media library,
trying to decide what to
watch, searching for a show,
or answering credential for
your favorite application,
using a traditional
keypad remote or even
a full-blown keyboard
from the couch,
make that experience complex.
On the other hand, technologies
like gyroscope and cameras
used as remote controls
resulted in a clumsy device
and still didn't solve the
complexity of interaction
model.
With full experiences
to control the TV
so prevalent in the marketplace,
more and more content
is being consumed on small
screens such as phone, tablet,
and laptops.
At the same time, the
mobile interaction model
is proving to be great for
navigation and control.
And while the portability of
the mobile devices and the user
experience is very convenient.
The actual consumption of the
video on those small screen
is subpar, particularly
in shared screen scenarios
like this, where
you want to show
your BFF your favorite
summer vacation
or you want to share the
latest biting movies.
There's no doubt that users
want to consume their content
on the largest
and most beautiful
screen available to them.
At the same time, rich
and immersive experience
is the best way to
navigate the UI.
And users are asking
for such experiences.
So why not give them
the best of both worlds?
The ubiquitous presence of the
mobile devices in their homes
mean that you, the
developer, do not
have to compromise
on form or function.
Users can get the same
application that they already
know and love on their
phones, tablets, and laptops,
and cast to the best
screen in the house,
while still using their mobile
device for email, web browsing,
social activities, or the
selection of the next video
they want to watch, all
without skipping a beat.
Let's get to the ecosystem.
Chromecast is a
tremendous success.
And it continues to
exceed our expectations.
Google Cast goes
beyond Chromecast,
and extends our reach
to more devices.
We want the consumer to
have a choice of devices
they use to consume
their content
in any room in the home.
And we want developers to
build their application
using a consistent
model for all devices.
As you've seen from
yesterday's keynote address,
in addition to Chromecast,
we've announced
support for Google Cast
on Android TVs, where
all the Google Cast
applications already
developed for Chromecast
would work seamlessly,
still using the same simple
Cast interaction model.
Of course, this being
Google, we wanted
to go big on the ecosystem
play for developers,
making it as easy as
possible to get your services
and experiences onto
all Cast devices.
And give you the
opportunity to reach
as many users as possible.
We started out with five
applications at launch.
And today we have thousands
more that integrate with Cast.
These apps are available
on Android and iOS,
as well as web apps in Chrome,
on Windows, Mac, and Chrome OS.
The SDK is published and
available for all developers
to integrate with.
You can Cast-enable
your app very easily.
All you need to do is
integrate discovery and control
with the Cast SDK, and
you're up and running.
We wanted to make the Cast
button ubiquitous in all apps,
obviously where it makes sense.
And to make that
possible, we enabled
the Cast SDK across the three
most popular platforms--
Android, iOS, and Chrome.
We do believe it is
critical to support
the heterogeneous mobile
device ecosystem you
find in households today.
And the user's data is proving
that to be a necessity.
Half of all Chromecast
devices in the last month
were used with mobile devices
from multiple platforms,
as you can see here.
Cross-platform
support does matter,
as my wife can attest to,
where she uses her iPhone along
with Chrome on Windows
laptop and an Android tablet
to watch her favorite
content and play
music throughout the house.
All on Chromecast.
Of course, one of our
most important goals
was to keep things
consistent and simple.
For users, we
wanted to make sure
that everything is
simple and easy to use.
And we did that by keeping
the casting experience very
close to your mobile experience.
And rather than teaching
users new ways to interface
with your app, we keep
them in the comfort
of their familiar settings
on their phones, tablets,
or laptops.
Whether they are playing
back music on the phone
or through the TV speakers,
using the Google Play Music
service, they do so
using the same play music
app and the same interface
to control that playback.
For developers we wanted to
keep things simple and easy
to integrate with by using
HTML5 for development
on Google Cast devices.
We harness the power
of Chrome, and the ease
of JavaScript development
and deployment.
We've also invested in
our media player library
to make the most streaming
format supported seamlessly.
And we continue to invest in
this area, adding more formats
and more features that opens
up the door for more content.
On the sender side,
our integration
on the supported platforms
is straightforward,
and integrates well with each
platform development model.
And we continue to invest in
adding more features as we
expand our application reach.
Also, we've introduced
strong UX guidelines
to make sure that the user
experience across applications
and devices, when you're
interacting with the TV,
is consistent, familiar, and
easy to understand by the user.
We never want to get the
user lost, or in a position
where they don't
know what to do next.
Let's talk a bit
about what trends
we're seeing in the field.
Media applications are
obviously the lion's share
of applications we're seeing.
And they straddle
three main facets.
Video is the first one.
Whether it's big names,
video streaming services
like Netflix, Hulu Plus, or HBO,
or smaller content aggregators,
using the big
screen for video has
been the obvious
choice for developers.
Music is the other
type of media that
is proving to be a great match
for the Cast interaction model.
It's so natural to control
an extensive playlist using
the phone.
And beautiful images
are a perfect candidate
for the large screen.
Showing and sharing
photos, whether personal,
or just beautiful pictures
that make the TV contributor
to the home decor,
pictures in general
make for a great
living room experience.
All of this content can be
served either from the Cloud,
your mobile device,
or a local cloud
from other devices in the home.
And with the ability to
connect multiple mobile devices
to a single session,
these media apps
can bring great use
cases such as party mode,
boarding, and sharing content.
And with the ease of
use of mobile devices,
these use cases
would truly shine.
We've talked a bit about media
apps in the living room, which
begs the question--
what about games?
Obviously a big screen is
better than a small one.
It's more beautiful, more
immersive, and more convenient
to use.
And for multiplayer games,
having your mobile device
being your controller allows
for things that are just not
possible using
traditional controllers.
For example, being able
to hide a hand of cards
from other players in
the room, or entering
text in a high-paced
trivia game,
these are things that
become trivially easy
in the Cast world.
An example of such
games is Big Web Quiz,
where multiple players are
competing with each other
using their phones to
make a selection presented
by the game.
We show you here
a quick video just
explaining how the thing works.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Catchy tune, huh?
You can also go and play this
game up on the third floor.
And you might even request
that tune for a ring tone.
We're seeing a good
number of games going live
with this model.
And there are a lot
of great opportunities
here for multiplayer space.
One other great
example of multi-center
is our very own home screen
on Chromecast called Backdrop.
Here you see a stream
of beautiful pictures
show up on the TV screen.
And everyone in the room
who pulls theri phone out
to interact with
the screen would
get a card describing
the item on the screen.
But each person would
get a different set
of actions associated
with this card based
on their behavior,
permission, and interest.
For example, in this
particular card,
you see here a picture of Paris.
John, who loves to
cook, might just
get actions related
to French recipes.
I, on the hand, love art.
And Backdrop might
just recommend
a virtual tour of the Louvre
or a new art exhibition related
to Paris that is running nearby.
This allows for a very
personalized experience
in the same app.
And now let me give
the stage to John.
JOHN AFFAKI: Thanks, Majd.
Thanks everyone.
I'm John Affaki, and I manage
the Google Cast SDK team.
And I'm going to talk to
you a little bit about some
of the features we're
currently working on.
First, I'd like to talk
about a feature we touched
on in the keynote yesterday,
which is the ability
to cast from the
ten nearby devices
without being on the
same Wi-Fi network.
One of the key things we've been
striving for while developing
Google Cast is keeping
things simple for users.
While casting today is an easy
task, low friction once you're
properly set up,
the initial step
of getting on the
same Wi-Fi network
can be really complicated.
It doesn't matter if
it's because you're
worried about the
privacy of your network,
whether you have 14 random
characters or characters that
would be really
hard to describe.
Sometimes you just don't
want to have your guests
on your Wi-Fi network.
And you want them to
be able to just cast
by simply being
in the same room.
So this new feature allows that.
It allows Google cast messages
sent through the Google Cast
SDK to be sent over the Cloud
between Google Cast devices
in your phones, or
tablets, or laptops,
without the need to be on
the same Wi-Fi network.
To enable the feature you
first go to the Chromecast app
and go to your devices
settings, and find the casting
from nearby device feature.
Enabling it allows
your cast device
to be discoverable
from nearby devices.
You only need to do this once,
unless you want to turn it off,
at which point you can go
back there and turn it off.
The other question everybody's
asking, well, nearby devices--
my neighbors-- weird
things can start happening.
But don't worry about that.
Basically, we have extra things
to protect you from that.
Let's walk through
an example to go
into a little bit more detail.
Let's say Majd, his
phone in his pocket,
walks into my living room,
where I have a Chromecast set up
with the feature enabled.
Now when Majd launches a
Cast-enabled application,
since the nearby Chromecast
device is detected--
and we use Android Location
Services with this--
the Cast icon will appear.
And when pressed, a
new route is going
to show up on his device
that says, nearby devices.
As you can see right there.
When the route's
selected, a PIN code
is ultrasonically played
through the TV speakers,
and my Chromecast gets
automatically connected.
Now the phone and
Chromecast exchange
a token via the
ultrasonic pairing,
and it temporarily
pairs the two devices.
At that point they
can talk to each other
through our cloud
over a TLS channel.
If for some reason,
the ultrasonic token
couldn't be exchanged, such
as if the TV was off or muted,
than the PIN code could
be manually entered
in that dialog to
get the same effect.
Now the PIN code can
be found on Backdrop.
You can see it right there.
But if Backdrop is invisible,
such as, again if the TV's off,
or if you're in the middle of
casting another application,
I can get the PIN for
Majd by looking it up
in my Chromecast app, since
I'm on the Wi-Fi network.
Now as a developer, this
feature is enabled for you
without any changes
needed in your app.
Any data that you send
through the Google Cast SDK
will be transparently sent
through this cloud channel.
But if you send other kind of
data, for example, local media,
then you'll be able to
opt out of this feature,
because otherwise we
can't send that data
through our cloud for now.
So this feature
really allows you
to build great social
experiences in your apps
without much worry about what
it takes to hop onto the network
and get users started.
Your users can just walk
in, tap the task icon,
and enjoy your app.
Second, let's talk about
some of the announcements
we made related to
Cast on Android TV.
So Android TV devices have
the exact same functionality
that you've come to
love with Chromecast.
Every Google Cast application
written for Chromecast
will work as is without any
modifications for Android TVs.
Now Android TVs typically
also have a remote control
along with Cast support.
And so let's walk
through an example.
Let's say my daughter
casts something
from her tablet
to my Android TV.
And I wanted to talk to her, but
I don't have my phone with me
to pause the media.
Now I can pick up the remote--
the Android TV remote--
and press a media command
like Pause or Stop,
and if the receiver application
was coded using the Google Cast
media name space,
then the application
would seamlessly receive the
message, the media messages,
exactly as if it had been
sent from a phone or tablet
or laptop without any changes
made to your application.
And the other thing is with more
and more Google Cast devices
coming up on the market, one of
the main things we wanted to do
was avoid fragmentation.
So in every Google Cast
device, whether Chromecast,
or any Android TV, we're
running the same Cast receiver
code which will be kept up to
date with background updates
by Google, which means your
users will always be running
the latest and greatest
Cast receivers.
Third, we announced support
for casting your Android screen
to cast devices.
Now when we first
launched Chromecast,
we introduced one of the
most popular features, which
was the ability to
cast a tab from Chrome.
Now this provided an easy way
to get all user's web content
onto Chromecast.
At the keynote
yesterday, we announced
that we'll be rolling
out screen casting, which
allows users to mirror their
Android displays onto Google
Cast devices.
Now this means as
a user, you could
project your native Android
apps, which may not yet
be Cast-enabled,
to the big screen
without the developer
needing to do any work.
However, with some changes,
you, as the developer,
can also extend your application
to use multiple displays when
this is enabled with the
secondary display being
mirrored onto your
Google Cast device.
You could do this by
opening up a presentation
display on the
secondary screen when
your app is being mirrored.
Now there's a lot
of applications
that benefit from screen
split experiences,
and they can now take
advantage of the big screen.
So for example, here
you can see this
is us earlier, presentation
apps with speakers notes
that could be on your phone
while you're projecting
the full blown
presentation on the TV.
You can also build
rich dual-screen games
that take full advantage
of the processing
power of your mobile device,
but the beautiful display
on your wall.
Fourth, let's talk a little
bit about enhancements
to media applications.
Now one of the biggest
items we launched
with the release of
the Google Cast SDK
was the Media Player Library,
bringing easy integration
for DASH, HLS, and
Smooth streaming
to media applications.
It really reduced
the amount of time
it takes to build
media applications
to a fraction of what it took
before during the preview
phase.
Now we're making constant
improvements to this library,
adding more formats
and trying to make
it even easier to
integrate with your apps.
Now it's because of this
library that the folks
on the live stream
right now are probably
ignoring us and watching the
Live Stream on Chromecast
for the US World Cup game.
Now accessibility is something
that we take very seriously
at Google.
And we know you guys do too.
So we're introducing
full support
for closed captioning
in the Google Cast SDK,
as well as in our
default players.
That means that
you, the developer,
don't need to build any custom
UI to deal with users' caption
settings, if you don't want to.
You could, and we'll take
those settings instead,
but we'll have
defaults in there.
And you can use
standardized messages
to manage the on/off settings.
No need to build a custom
name space to deal with
closed captioning anymore.
Now your users will be able
to set their caption settings
on their mobile
device settings page,
and they'll be used on
the Google Cast devices.
And that means that each user
can have personalized caption
settings and manage
their own preferences.
They'll persist, regardless
of which Google Cast device
you cast to.
Now this will be rolled
out over the next few weeks
as we roll out the
update to the SDK.
Now there are some
mobile devices
that don't support
setting caption
settings for the mobile device.
And so the users will be able
to go to the Chromecast app
to set defaults for the
Google Cast devices.
And those will be used
if the settings aren't
available on the phone.
And that'll come a little
bit later this year.
Alright, let's
talk about queuing.
So for most music apps
and many video apps,
queuing is pretty
much a prerequisite.
But there hasn't been a
unified way of building queues.
Every single app that
uses queuing today
builds them in their own way.
So we're working on adding
a standardized queuing
API to our SDK which will handle
the logistics of creating,
modifying, and managing
queues of media item.
That means that you as an app
developer can simply add items
to your queue, and if you're
using our default players,
will automatically take
care of playing them back
in the right order, and dealing
with any kind of reorder.
This will be a full
fledged API which
allows you to insert,
remove, reorder items,
and anything you'd
expect from a queue.
We're also building in
full-featured media controls
onto mobile devices,
allowing users
to interact with
whatever's currently
playing with regards to
media from any device.
Now, I'll go through an example.
If I'm playing back media from
an application on my laptop,
and my wife were to
pick up her tablet,
which wouldn't have the
corresponding Android or iOS
app associated with that
app, and she would still
be able to pause, resume,
seek, and any common media
action that you'd take simply
because her application was
built using the standard
media name space.
Now authentication and
credential exchange
is another challenge that
the majority of developers
have to deal with.
We're also working
on a providing
a simple, secure way to
deal with the transfer
of credentials from
senders to receivers,
so that your services
can seamlessly
authenticate on Google Cast.
Now this will be
integrated with queueing
so that if different
items in your queue
require different
credentials, you
could pass the token
at insert time,
and you won't have to deal
with it at playback time.
For example, in an app
where, say Majd and I wanted
to add music to a queue, and the
service required authentication
for each item, Majd
could add the item
and his token would
be passed along
with the item in the queue.
I would add something
to the queue
and my credentials
would be passed.
We could toss our phones out the
window, drive over the phone,
or whatever, doesn't
really matter.
And the playback would be
able to go back smoothly
because the credentials
were already there.
So we're adding more
features to the SDK,
but another key area
that we're investing in
is to make sure that your
users can find your apps.
I mean APIs are key,
but an app is only great
if it can reach its users.
So we're making it easier for
them to find your applications.
At the keynote yesterday, we
talked about the redesigned
chromecast.com/apps website,
which allowed users to browse
and find apps for
all of our platforms.
Now a few weeks ago, we released
an updated developer console
which allowed us to gather
information and assets
to use to feature your apps.
And as more and more
developers enter their data
in the console, you'll see
their apps show up on the site.
But that's just the beginning,
and more discovery features
are coming to the website.
We're also making
improvements to the Play Store
to make it even easier to
search for Cast-enabled apps.
This will bring relevant
recommended applications
to Cast users to the forefront.
We're also going to build in
support in the Chromecast app
to surface apps that our
users already have installed,
but actually don't
know are cast-enabled.
So they'll be able to discover
them from the Chromecast app.
Finally, I'm going to talk
to you about some use cases
beyond media.
As Majd said
earlier, the majority
of the apps that we're seeing
are media applications.
And much of that is
because we're heavily
focused on making that happen.
Now there are
however, many areas
where we're seeing quite
a few apps show up.
And over the next year
we'll be making enhancements
to the Google Cast
SDK across the board
to make it even easier for you
guys to enable the scenarios.
Now the living room TV is
mainly used for two reasons.
The first one is
obvious, and it's media,
and we talked about that.
The second one is gaming.
Now with the number
of daily active users
of mobile devices
absolutely dwarfing
the overall number of
active console users,
the audience for
multi-screen games is huge.
Now the interaction model
enabled by the devices
that users already
have today allow
you to create games
that simply aren't
practical to build
on your platform.
With the phone for example,
users have a controller,
they have a great touch screen,
a beautiful display, a camera,
a microphone, a gyroscope,
and an accelerometer.
And you can create
multiplayer games
that anyone can join
without the need
to purchase any
additional custom hardware
and use all these features.
Now as a sometime
lazy parent, I'm
as guilty as anyone of using
the TV as a babysitter, which
gives it a really bad rap.
With Google Cast,
you could build
creative educational
software that
can now make me look
like a smart babysitter
for using the TV.
Now with the big screen being
used to watch video clips
or images, for example, the
entire surface of my child's
touchscreen could be
used for interactions,
either via drawing,
or keyboards,
or whatever interaction
model you choose to have.
Those hands may be
little, but they really
need a lot more
surface than ours do.
Now, another great
use case would
be adding in
multi-center capabilities
into those educational games.
For example, you can give
the ability for a parent
to provide help or assistance
to a child from a second device
while they're playing their
game on the first one,
so that it doesn't interfere
with your child's touch screen
experience, and builds
their confidence.
Now going beyond
the living room,
the usage of cast
devices in classrooms
can make for a really
immersive experience.
In more and more
cases, students are
encouraged to use tablets or
laptops for their classes.
Now whether it's for classroom
presentations, real time
quizzes, or just to drill
deeper into whatever
the teacher's
currently presenting,
being able to interact
with the classroom just
keeps students engaged.
Now Enterprise is also a space
where using a Cast remote
is pretty much a
daily occurrence.
For example, being able to cast
a presentation-- like we're
doing today, drive
a video conference--
we do that all the time, or
even simple, obvious use cases
like digital signage.
There are thousands
of use cases that
can be enabled by Google
Cast in the Enterprise.
For example, this guy
probably would have something
up on the screen if
he used Google Cast.
As you can see,
there's a lot of room
for innovative,
fresh, impactful apps.
And we're here to help.
The main thing we want you folks
to get out of this presentation
is that we're evolving the
Google Cast ecosystem based off
of what you guys are telling us.
We're constantly
listening to the feedback,
trolling the forums, looking at
the developer community on G +.
And we were looking to see what
you guys want us to improve on.
And so we want you to
keep that feedback coming,
because we're really
only just beginning.
So if you want to learn more
about Google Cast-- well,
you're here-- you probably
know much about it.
But if you want to
learn more about it,
you can find more information
at google.com/cast
and developer.google.com/cast.
So we're going to take the
rest of the time for questions.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Sasha Goldman from
DistinctMEDIA.
I have two questions.
First of all, you described
the new great features
that you will have in the
media player extension,
like closed captions.
Does it apply to the
custom receivers as well?
JOHN AFFAKI: Yeah.
So with the custom receivers,
you'll be able to access,
let's take queuing for example.
You'll have a queue object,
and you will get events
when an item finishes
playing and there
will be hooks for
you to do whatever
it is that you're doing.
So for example, if you were
to not use a standard video
tag to play back, you'll get
an event which will tell you,
hey, you should be
playing back this item.
So there will be hooks in
order for you to do that.
We just can't do full
playback because we
don't know exactly what your
custom application will be,
how your custom
application interacts.
But yeah, all of these features
will be usable by that.
They just need a
little bit more work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And second question,
I asked that before.
And I'm wondering
if anything changed
in opening your open platform to
other platforms like Microsoft
on Google Cast SDK site?
MAJD BAKAR: So we
evaluate the addition
of a new platform based
on popularity and usage.
As other platforms
become more popular,
we'll investigate that.
JOHN AFFAKI: Yeah,
I mean we obviously
have support for
Windows on Chrome.
And we see a lot of applications
being developed there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
Chrome's getting great.
And I remember take
the Chrome notes
and embed it in
your application,
which is impractical.
Question is, actually
have that dot Net,
C Sharp SDK that
we can integrate
in our existing lines
of the products.
Right now we can't support Roku.
We can't support Xbox 1.
We cannot support Chromecast.
And we support Chromecast on any
other platforms except Windows.
And basically as products
from our product perspective,
we're abandoning our customers
on the Windows side, which
is actually quite
large by popularity
from our point of view.
That's the practicality
of that question.
Thank you.
JOHN AFFAKI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Have you
guys worked at all
with the Chrome
remote desktop team?
Essentially turning
Chromecast into anywhere
VPNs, to turn any screen
into whatever computer
you're connecting to?
JOHN AFFAKI: We constantly are
talking to the Chrome team.
One of the challenges
there is how you actually
deal with the extension.
Do you mean like the
ability to promote
into your desktop from say,
your mobile device, and--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So if I was to
take my Chromecast,
plug it in this projector,
remote into my computer
at home, and have a keyboard
connected to the Chromecast
essentially turn the
screen into my computer
from home streaming.
MAJD BAKAR: It's an
interesting use case.
We need to discuss it with
the remote staff team.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Dell came out with a USP
HDMI 6 similar to you guys
that essentially runs an
entire computer on there.
So you can turn any
screen into a computer.
But with Chromecast
being so light,
and the Chrome
remote desktop team
making such amazing advances
on that side, mending the two
together could almost turn
that into an anywhere platform.
MAJD BAKAR: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
about the devices
which are not on Wi-Fi.
Will not be a discovery option
if the content stream is local.
JOHN AFFAKI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'm building
an application which
is streaming local content now.
Do I need to make any
changes to tell the casting
service that my content
is local and not
coming from a foreign location?
JOHN AFFAKI: So when you
talk about local content,
you mean content on your phone
or on your tablet, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOHN AFFAKI: So one
of the main challenges
is the Cloud messaging system
is optimized for the Google Cast
SDK, which usually is somewhat
short burst messages, which
is mostly about notifying
your application.
And so we're not right now
ready to deal with say,
a five gigabyte file that you'll
be streaming through there.
Now if you were dealing
with local content
say, with the ability
to-- you could probably
pass a URL that may be
accessible from the Cloud,
and you would be
able to stream it.
But your URL, in
typical cases, you'd
be opening up a local port,
say 192 address space.
You wouldn't be able to
stream your media that way.
But if you were to
open up something
that could go through the
NAT and the open internet,
then you'd be able to stream it.
We just can't send
large media file.
Essentially the Google
Cast SDK channels
are really meant for
notifications and messages.
AUDIENCE: True, but
so in that case,
how do I make sure
my application
to have the opt-out
option for the user.
JOHN AFFAKI: Well, we won't
be able to have the option.
Essentially when we
talk about opt out
of this feature, because
essentially you might end up
with a somewhat broken
experience, where you think
your address is 192,
blah, blah, blah,
and the cast device on the
other side is going to go,
yeah, it's not.
And so in the developer portal,
in the developer console,
you'll be able to
basically opt out
of local discovery, which
means that in your application,
the user will not see
the nearby devices.
AUDIENCE: Fine.
That's what I was looking for.
JOHN AFFAKI: As much
as we want to make sure
that all your use
cases are there,
we really want to make sure
we protect the end user also.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Any new word on
casting from your desktop,
but not using Chrome?
So if you have a DVD
or a Blu-ray disc
to put in your laptop, and you
want to stream it that way.
Because I know you guys
are working on that,
and you're having
audio problems,
from what I've looked up.
JOHN AFFAKI: Do you mean the
desktop mirroring feature?
MAJD BAKAR: You are talking
about mirroring, or casting?
The commanding control?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like casting
your desktop on the screen.
MAJD BAKAR: So we
continue to investigate.
This is currently an
experimental feature.
We're experimenting with that.
There are challenges into
mirroring the full desktop.
And we're still working on that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are you guys
looking into doing primitives
for images or slide shows?
JOHN AFFAKI: Do you
mean like for example,
the equivalent of a
default player for that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah exactly.
Like you have a media
player for video.
Would you have a slide
show player for images?
JOHN AFFAKI: I believe our
default players actually
allow you to at least
cast one image right now.
And as we'll add queuing, we'll
have support for images also,
as part of those.
So you'll be able to essentially
add images to a queue.
AUDIENCE: Without
any other media,
and it'll cycle through them.
JOHN AFFAKI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Along those lines,
we noticed a lot of apps
that you can cast
photos and slide shows,
but one thing about
those, to me at least,
they're boring without music.
So it would require
I guess two streams,
but is there any opportunity
there to be able to cast like,
photos from a source
and music as well?
JOHN AFFAKI: You mean
from different sources?
There's nothing today
preventing any application
from playing back audio
and showing photos
at the same time.
Essentially, if you think
about what Chromecast is,
you've got the
full power of HTML.
And as far as I know,
you can actually
play back audio and video, or
audio and images on the web.
Right?
I mean, obviously.
Sorry.
And so in this particular
case, if you're
talking about say, being
able to cast Google Play
Music while doing
your photos, we
have no plans of
allowing two applications
to run in parallel on that.
Mostly because the
interaction model for users
might get very complicated.
AUDIENCE: That's true.
JOHN AFFAKI: But there's nothing
preventing an application,
for example, from deciding to
be able to play background music
or allow you to cast from audio
and photos at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Is that something
the Android TV would
be able to solve, if
somebody wanted to cast
play music and have their photos
streaming at the same time?
MAJD BAKAR: You still have the
same problem with the user.
If the user is using their
phone, if they want to pause,
which one do they want to pause.
So until we figure out how to
do that on the sender side,
it's irrelevant of
what receiver it is.
JOHN AFFAKI: It's not really
a platform limitation.
We're trying to make sure that
the interaction model is great.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What's going
to be the audio and video
latency for the new mirroring
feature from Android
to Chromecast?
MAJD BAKAR: We're trying to make
it as low latency as possible.
We're not going to publish
a number at this time.
As was announced yesterday,
it's still beta feature.
AUDIENCE: So is it
going to be faster
or slower than from the browser?
MAJD BAKAR: It should be faster.
I mean, lower latency.
JOHN AFFAKI: I mean, you
saw the demo yesterday.
And you'll be seeing
it very shortly.
I mean, we've been
play testing it
with games and all
sorts of things,
so it's very responsive.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Same question.
Thank you.
JOHN AFFAKI: Two-for.
AUDIENCE: I haven't played
with this in a little bit,
so it might have gotten better.
But I remember we were
working on in our office
having a bunch of
default applications
running on these
Chromecasts, and then we
want people to be able to
put something up, and then
have that application seamlessly
come back when they're done.
And I remember we were
having some difficulties.
Kind of like writing our own
screen saver sort of thing.
Is there any plan to put
in APIs to easily support
having your own version
of a screen saver
for the Chromecast?
JOHN AFFAKI: Yes and no.
Not as a complete
replacement for Backdrop.
But as Rishi
announced yesterday,
we're going to be talking
to third party developers
to have the ability
for them to add
their own feeds into Backdrop.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So with the screen
mirroring, is there
going to be an option for
individual applications
to turn that off?
Say for example, for apps that
may have the rights to display
video on the small screen,
but not on the big screen?
MAJD BAKAR: So this
is-- on Android,
it's a system function.
And depending on the
level of security
you have in terms of
content protection,
you'd be able control that.
This is all part of the
presentation API in Android.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Since you're adding
media control from the Android
TV remote to
Chromecast, would it
be possible to do the same with
HDMI CC on the old Chromecast?
MAJD BAKAR: It's
a great feature.
We're looking into that.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any timeline as far as
when the queue API and
some of the other things
that you talked
about are going to be
actually live on Chromecast?
JOHN AFFAKI: So the
closed captioning APIs
are essentially rolled out.
We talked about rolling
out the new Google Play
Services with screen
casting and closed
captioning as part of that.
So it'll be over
the next few weeks.
We're talking about
queuing and ID delegation.
We're currently working on that.
And it's soon.
It's going to be an
upcoming release.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I just had a question
about the video file types
that Chromecast supports.
Will there be an update to that?
Or is it a limitation
to the hardware?
I know currently you
can use something
like Plex or
something, but you have
to run a server on a computer.
Is there going to be an
update to maybe codecs?
MAJD BAKAR: On the codec
itself, unfortunately it's
a hardware limitation.
But on the container
and transport stream,
that we are adding as we go.
So codec, it's H.264 up to
high profile as well as VP8
on video.
On audio we have a
much larger list.
In terms of streaming format,
we support the MP4 base
and the Impact 2TS base,
but we are adding as we go.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When
casting, I would love
to be able to put my
headphones in my phone,
and then get the
music from the TV.
So are you taking that
into consideration?
And do you have a best practice
or best approach for that?
MAJD BAKAR: The
trick there is making
sure you have the
synchronization right.
Over Wi-Fi, things
become challenging.
But it is definitely an
area of investment for us.
We still don't have an answer.
So I'm sorry.
I don't have the
silver bullet here.
But we're looking into
ways to make it easier.
So we provide you with
some timing information,
so you can synchronize
audio and video.
AUDIENCE: Romain from
France, France [INAUDIBLE].
And we recently released a
Chromecast enabled application
on Android, which is France 24.
And we had problems
integrating the live stream
of our channel because
of cross domain policies.
Do you plan on lowering
restrictions or giving
guidelines for standard
streaming solutions,
like for the media server?
MAJD BAKAR: Go ahead.
JOHN AFFAKI: So
cross domain auth
is something that the web
is dealing with, right?
And the reason the
majority of apps
don't run into
this on normal web,
is because most use Flash--
less and less-- but many
are using Flash.
So we want to keep the
development process
as close as possible
to the web development
process, which means that at
least for now, cross domain
auth is staying.
I think Leon Nichols
posted something
on the developer forum--
MAJD BAKAR: Guidelines.
JOHN AFFAKI: Sorry?
JOHN AFFAKI: Yeah,
some guidelines
on how to deal with it.
We know this is a
challenge for many people,
particularly during
development, because once you
go to production, you're
a little bit more set up.
But developing from
your dev machine,
it's always harder
to get a live stream.
So we're looking into
ways of making it easier.
But cross domain
auth is here to say.
MAJD BAKAR: And also we're
working with Mint player
in the industry,
particular CDN providers
to find alternatives as well.
Make it easier for developers.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are you
looking at getting
five gigahertz or other Wi-Fi
protocols like Enterprise
security supported
on the hardware,
either through a Gen
2 or Android TVs?
MAJD BAKAR: So we can't
talk about future hardware.
But these are stuff that
are interesting for us.
AUDIENCE: Since the
hardware capabilities
of Android TV and
the old Chromecast
is different,
especially regarding
codec supported in
encryption, and so on.
Is there going to be any
difference in support
of video files in
Chromecast on Android TV?
MAJD BAKAR: So actually,
it will be identical.
We are putting all the
hardware requirements
in terms of codec,
DRM, and streaming
as part of the Android
TV requirement.
And whatever runs on Chromecast
would run on Android TV.
AUDIENCE: So for example,
if I had a 4K source,
I wouldn't be able to play
through Chromecast on Android
TV?
MAJD BAKAR: No.
So this is the last
question because we
are running out of time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
We are developing an
app for the Kindle Fire,
and when we are using
the Chromecast SDK,
it usually Google
Play framework.
So is there a way to using
other non Google Play--
MAJD BAKAR: Unfortunately
at this moment,
that's not possible.
The SDK is part of the
Google Play services,
and it's not available.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
MAJD BAKAR: So I want to
make one last announcement.
Before you leave, if you
go at the corner there,
we're giving away
free Chromecasts.
Thank you for attending.
JOHN AFFAKI: Thank you.